[Musik]
das geht absolut ruhig bin erkältet
letzten blog habt ihr gesehen dass doch
der erste partie von max neuer uni waren
deswegen mache ihr seht schon dass das
irgendwie andere stativ ist es nicht
ganz einfach daran dass man normale
stativ das liegt noch bei ihrem autoren
ich mal freute wenn nicht engagierter
blogger sind jetzt beim auslaufen
meinestadt.de ich bin fußballer der welt
ist auf jeden fall besser weil ersten
partner von maximal grund habe ich mich
irgendwie ein bisschen erkältet war da
noch relativ lang war die so bis 4 uhr
deswegen als man das übel das man sich
das beim reiter das ist nicht irgendein
zu stehen kommen ich mache jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal schon vom vater
vorstellen wie es vom vortag der plan
heute mit seinen armen seines landes
fragen sind
ich würde sagen das machen wir heute mal
ansehen mussten feiertages heute dienst
habe ich jetzt was heute abend kommt
unseren kleinen moment leiden unsere
beste folgenden tages am brenner
potenzielle denn wenn nicht überhaupt
besteht auf jeden fall mache ich mir
jetzt erst mal auf ich hab mir schon was
gegessen also ich bin da freuen sich
dass man nie genug essen an im leben
aber jetzt habe ich echt eigentlich gar
keine nummer dann scheide ich jetzt
erstmal den blog den er sich vor zwei
tagen gesehen ob das wir sehen uns in
drei stunden wieder
glaube premiere ich weiß echt nicht was
ich falsch mache aber was ist das hier
jetzt schon wieder für beschissen
auffiel ich bestelle mir erst mal was zu
essen jetzt helfen jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich nordsee ich bin euer essen ja
echt lecker aber das hier für 15 euro
also ein kleines stück fisch das ist
echt ultra klein um 6 kartoffeln wollt
ihr mich verarschen jetzt übrigens
gerade ist mir aufgefallen dass ich
eigentlich ein beschissener blogger bin
das ist einerseits 18 boden ich habe
noch fast gar nichts gefühlt heute und
andererseits liegt mit stativ die ganze
zeit unten in der tiefgarage in meinem
auto und ich bin zu faul dazu hole ich
freue mich auf jeden fall die
spülmaschine hause benutzer einfach
gerade im stuhl da vorne alte die
spülmaschine ist gar nicht frisch wieder
raus sonst ja mein letztes dieses mini
skateboard wiedergefunden das geile ist
halt ich kann damit jetzt echt
mittlerweile schon ein paar tricks also
ich kann das schlechte leben gemacht
das weiß nicht so gut
ich werde mich jetzt denke ich mal ein
neues mixtape setzen und da so ein
bisschen herumwerkeln bauleiter
nach vier stunden habe ich mein neues
mixa wird werde ich schon bevor wieder
dass viele die kommentare kommt von
wegen letzte nicht auf youtube ist oder
doch von cloud ich habe dann einfach
nicht so richtig die rechte die schon
mehrmals gesagt sind die auf soundcloud
einfach so ein bisschen kulanter was die
ganze rechte sache angeht im vergleich
zu youtube dass ich demnächst helfen
nicht nicht auf youtube hoch weil ich
auf soundcloud indem er geld verdienen
oder so dass ich gar nix also es liegt
aber daran dass es auf youtube gesperrt
werden würde aber ich mache jetzt erst
mal was zu essen ich es schon wieder den
dreisten ich habe heute morgen gegessen
habe mein neues mixtape sondern auf
meinen sound laut profil link in der
beschreibung text gerne mal aus freunde
sowie meinte er dass jetzt gerade auf
einem parkplatz auf dem parkplatz
angekommen deswegen werde ich erst mal
mit dem auto abholen fahren
[Musik]
die biester wir sind jetzt wieder zu
hause bei mir angekommen gleich kommen
noch zwei freunde hin rum und dann
wollten wir mal gucken was vernommen
machen das eigentlich wollten wir noch
irgendwo hingehen weil das ist heute
samstag aber irgendwie keine ahnung wo
wir alle stellen was sagst du dazu dass
du dazu hoch genommen wird das passt
also dem steigenberger gruppe waren sagt
im körper fenster vorfall so war schön
also fast so wie ein auto ist einfach
schön sehr schön
wir sind vom feiern jetzt aus einem
schönen töne hier am start von ballett á
la galette ballack auf jeden fall gehen
wir jetzt erstmal schlafen freuen ich
bin auf jeden fall hart müde
deswegen würde ich direkt sagen beide
damen und herren schönen guten morgen es
ist gerade sehe nur ihr habt
wahrscheinlich schon titel gelesen aber
heute ist der tag gekommen an dem ich
leider den porsche abgeben musste ich
bin gerade noch in köln der pause wieder
zu hause bei der familie fällt abgeholt
und müsse man eigentlich nicht mehr
morgen für seinen fuß stehe und nicht zu
sagen was am papier sagen
es sei wichtig die frau war jetzt das
tor steht ja noch mal auf jeden fall
werde ich denke ich nach heimat café ich
werde jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal nach
bielefeld fahren weil wie gesagt da hat
der forscher abgeholt wird und dann
werde ich noch ein bisschen die ganzen
sache dass hierdurch ein fazit ziehen
bis ich habe mich mittlerweile schon
voll an dieses auto gewöhnen an diese
schöne alcantara lenkrad diese perfekt
angepassten sitze macht er steige ich
wieder mal mini also ich meine megageil
caro und ich freue mich auch kein mini
wieder zu haben oder ob es doch mal zu
einer pünktlichkeit im ringcenter die
karte abholen will welche wieder fällt
ist um 12 42 da und ich bin um 13 38 sc
bielefeld
wtf deutschland das blaue ich bin zu
hause angekommen meine damen und herren
nicht auf dem hof und jetzt heißt es für
mich abschied nehmen ihr seht es bereits
im titel eingeblendet dieses schöne auto
dieser 911 carrera gts ist ist das
leider geschichte in meinem leben die
ich schon mehrmals gesagt habe ich
dieses auto von porsche bekommen im
rahmen des carrera cups der jetzt am
nürburgring war wo er auch den block
gesehen haben ich muss sagen meine damen
und herren hand aufs herz ich habe mich
verliebt in dieses auto ich hatte ja
letztes jahr schon mal 911 der war schon
mega geil aber diese neuen bts modelle
vor allem als kabel diesmal mega ist das
war auf jeden fall eine super geile zeit
mit diesem auto ich kann es nicht oft
genug sagen mir fehlen ein bisschen die
worte ich zeige euch jetzt noch mal so
ein paar szenen mit schöner musik
[Musik]
das gerade aufnahmen von dem gts ich
weiß dass andere youtuber oft sogar
points machen mit so einer krassen
treppen ok import keine ahnung was mit
zu krassen drops und so ich finde das
auch mega gar nicht gucken was mir ja
gerne an den gp oder so das machen aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde
der 911 carrera gts es ist einfach kein
das ist dass ich bin das ich hasse ich
wollte das ist einfach ein wunderschönes
auto und ich finde da musste jetzt
einfach so eine schöne ruhige musik in
ich hoffe ihr hattet auch so ein
bisschen spaß daran in den letzten block
wie ich mich halt mal gefreut hat dieses
auto zu fahren und dass ich die
möglichkeit hatte dieses auto fahren zu
dürfen jetzt zwei wochen und breiter
front
ich weiß nicht wo der auf einmal
herkommen
den hatte ich früher als stofftier und
er ist eigentlich ganz neu ist der ultra
flauschig vor allem auf jeden fall mache
ich mir jetzt erst mal was zu essen weil
dafür hatte ich heute morgen in köln da
keine zeit mehr hat aber leider ist
porsche jetzt erst richtig lag jetzt
gerade noch kurz ein bisschen draussen
weil das wetter noch ganz schön war und
ich würde es wirklich sagen da dieser
ganzen block schon so ein bisschen davon
handelt das ist der porsche weg ist und
so beantworte ich jetzt noch ein paar
fragen die ihr mir zum auto stellt
wieviel km/h hd ab wieviel
stundenkilometer hat der händen kannst
den mit 10 km/h fahren waren 300 ist es
als autonom auf wie viel ps krank haben
einen porsche fahren der hat 450 ps
was ist das nochmal für ein auto bmw
bist du dumm wie groß ist ein penis
tätigen wollte nicht alle verarschen
alter hat der porsche hat gestunken wie
du
ich würde sagen belasten das mit den
fragen auch wenn es jetzt nicht so krass
drüberkommen bei halt meine art zu
blocken immer so ein bisschen so spaß
schließlich ist muss ich sagen ich bin
riesige auto fan ich habe mich unter
gefreut als oliver von porsche sagte wir
können in den neuen carrera gts für zwei
wochen geben hätte da bock drauf als ich
bin nicht aus ihrer häuser also ich bin
komplett ausgerastet habe ich vor
gericht ich bin eigentlich eher mehr
oldtimer fan und kenne mich da ein
bisschen mehr aus also ich kann euch
jetzt nicht darum was von den neuen
mercedes modellen beispielsweise da
gibt's mittlerweile alle möglichen suvs
allein schon wieder produktportfolio der
glk glc glg klasse um auf den punkt zu
kommen es war einfach sehr sehr geil ins
auto ist für zwei wochen zu haben ich
habe sehr häufig die frage gestellt
bekommen würdest du dir auch so ein auto
kaufen halt deine scheiss fresse ich
kann diese frage nicht richtig
beantworten ich finde das auto megageil
es hat wohl trotzdem spaß gemacht aber
die farbe war ein bisschen zu auffällig
meine meinung hier ist nicht gekauft von
porsche also ich könnte auch sagen jetzt
habe ich total abgefuckt mit dieser tage
um zu erfahren was es aber nicht getan
hat aber ich bin ganz ehrlich hätte ich
mir irgendwann sportwagen kaufen sollte
oder so ich würde immer nur schwarz
neben alles schwarzen nicht mal nicht
wie andere nähte oder hier gelbe akzente
oder ihr rote dies und das und planet
alles schwarz also die farbe jetzt war
ultra geil aber ich glaube das sieht man
sich relativ schnell satt dran deswegen
wenn ich mir so ein auto hole
widerwillig mit definitiven nur in
schwarz holen und ich mache jetzt was zu
essen
schild ich kaufe mir übrigens nudeln
also sonderlast nähe gekauft ich habe
ich ja die ganze zeit gefragt diese
teile der antiken die da so rein
gesteckt sind oder so aber das ist
einfach mal wichtig ist geil alter haben
einfach noch mehr verlieren brauchen so
magnetisch das auch nicht es ist
natürlich gut geschmeckt ich werde okay
es war spaghetti bolognese das kann ich
unglaublich scheiße schmecken man merkt
dass es winter wird und zwar die sonne
ist gerade einfach binnen kürzester zeit
runter gegangen ich habe hier noch so
sehr an dieser stelle würde ich den
heutigen doch dann allerdings auch
beenden ich habe morgen früh in den
arzttermin um 8 uhr deswegen muss ich da
auf jeden fall früher aufstehen oder
outfit sein deswegen werde ich jetzt
schlafen gehen werde durch diesen
gefallen hat so ein bisschen der
rückblick auf die besten zeiten mit dem
porsche und das habe ich dir noch
abgegeben und so weiter und so fort
dann will ich mich selber gleich von
euch freuen und wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent sei dass ihr habt irgendwas
falsch gemacht im leben dann könnt ihr
einfach unter dem video hier auf
abonnieren klicken dann verpasste keine
videos mehr das ist sogar bestätigt von
bellof dass man dann besserer mensch
wird im nächsten block werde ich auch
mal wieder ein kommentiert kommentare
machen das heißt ihr könnt jetzt auch
noch fleißig kommentare in die
kommentare schreiben wo er doch sonst zu
fragen jobs und irgendein anderer
scheiße irgendwie sowas und sonst will
ich sagen wir uns jetzt in zwei tagen
wieder
[Musik]